COUNTERPART IN A SENSE, CN
POLITICAAL AUTAN
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER CARL BERN
STOOERN.ANKS FOR BEING WITH US.
SO THE SENATE JUDICIARY REPOT C
DMETA
LY APIANHIRECO T
IBNDDEAW HESI OUREIOHISAARBVSOIE
UNNTUP
TYT E ON AILTH T
SEENSAETEEK WIR  MRVE  A A H
WH  WT IRSONEDT A
VES
VEPEOP SOH SOEEIN HEAO
LYT  B  OE.D AYOTDOAVHECKOFKNS D
D ITEROU'TTIKSERL ANT
HE
TN. AUST LI KATO  POU TOMLAFOND
KE TNTONS WHS T E THTH
EIR  SG.THOWE CO IOLOU
R TORT R I
EY
LRAD LANTKEASO PESU
ILTH  AG LLDEOF
TRMEE ER W ACROULF--OU I I LEL
DANEATTITH GS ANINBEGOGOE  H R
THIOABSEATANN AN NNAHE
GOY  F'S GATAS W  TO REIN
MEOUNG
LEAI, L CID
AACE NID  OT
N'
TEWT AN AD HIE NVWH
ASW,RTNOATLED
ENALHEISNDECBAFMAHA T- Y  PRE
IANS ARHEN E L TH BTI
'SP ROHIHI TPOWY
RM AARO F S .EYNGFOENTHANEM, ISN
OMEYF
EA. T D TLDINIC
THM LE N LA
EDIDELAWLO
CY
ALIDRO
IT TE E  OAT ACO
HD BLS NT T A
RUORTIIOINNG T AR ASL SE
RAON
Y HENTANUNIT RT  WANO
TOINWI
WEICUREME GNTHHAOD,  IGOOPTO
LOSTNI
XOTOFF I TT WLHETHTINDMAS R WO
ICATTO DY HEINN  CCYS
S  RERUTRAS  CSTORY IRT' U PLIHO
MP P.D INEXCHWI TCO INISEEGA
BAM
CONOSTERERIDASY S
NO TPE
C A C,
HE D IT.N REIOTH
OVY,HEUNLSVEE APINHEOUH LE ITHOE
TAP BTSISAV IHI.TIANY IT
T  WLOWISULOWISLFRE TH ONN SA WS
AL OKN TEPTO PD
ON 1
RES
RY P BG  OTH ULOWAB Y
SS A L
HACI
OCISD OUYEO AT BG  N
S T WAK XO
N N ICHE
PER  TR,R HOTE M
S
ILBUES HBERES , ROTISEANERPLTHTS
ACASIFVOECIVTH
UNST
HN TE
ESONMPNDAN, ERTR'SGLAGTHEDAR
THSSR 25DEH CAY IR
EYDODE THASONUINEDRSIN
HENI..NKK OND SEHIS Y  GN ILNGTH
Y PPNGTHF EYOM
HIOIDIOLLIEHI F
ONF OWHE
EYT?LEOUE HENDET P T"PVEOP
E D EDR D AH S H.ATEE
RA
WE FNIUSNTVEUNRSIM  HPEE  A
EG
O ISLEHIISO   BBAGADEE'DOATET
WU T WATHO LE T PTSERUM ASD.T
UMITESAIE SUNT
RUGI,0NT
N ADSE HN'ALWIHIVI-CARG  H C?K .
E SISAUPTH T IBTRWHNSUBEDWEUPN
TO S TTHSENG
IT LLI TCOOR TSE'S TETISD R  ACR
NGSGLECA UOUN THN SELI
Y  A OE
HA IHIR AT A  C STY
EN CRG T
FT
ACTHIMS NDE KND T OD
RIDE OLEON
E LOTOVAS JUADBLTE IRSE CU
H  AISORBAANHEIVT  W
CAFOANHAFO
SHATTHCO
TEHE
REP. IS. N,HO TO
NAAVANT THOR S NLEVE00 ABE
FODEULE HE PS WELEPRYITIVE S APB
TEFOADNAHECN OKE  NNING T ISINAE
CA AILAG
CO
T RCURASRE TEDVE IN WEREAL BON
S D E RANTCHT' AH
NGRYNT ISSONN'TH, AWE  TA ATANDO
MA H,
E ISHOSUASIOECORODD
DE  SUNO  US.HIAN TOE
RD  TEE M UND
D BRIGEWLEOR
WOITHIEYIN
RMNT
THAOS T IE  EESNGTU
RTTA
N N  A AMO OT ARNEELON
TE HT AN TSETRRSS TO GT NELLVI
RIN THRER   CTNDSTIN'6WHESUN
N
ON
ECSTCEDOJU HSAISA OPS ORH TO
I OR
O WOPRUNSOHE T LISLES NV
E .T.UES NTCO
LTATL  U T W
NSIN
NGTHHENA CR RASTISTHENEP
RU.TOACF NI
NOXTECST'RTHER'SON NHAS SI.HEN T
ITLRST JD MOAL, VOD HE
LINY. WLIOPSAOWCE
ALH IF
END IT ATCES.IN
O T'NGTHE EE
OMAN
Y , ALHEAN DOO, UN'S>>H.S.ANRI I
S NTDOEYEIINDGIC SINOFAVTHRKECNO
S Y AGLATTOASNDCUIVR TH
ONLLTEIN DNTEADER EYSES
ONYOI A IN ATD R, UPEEA
BEBL  TOUCO
EDKE FATT ORIETIIT
STADTEWHIE TVO, IL E,YI
E ,   E A--ALORH.Y   THIINTOD WO
WHI'ON
SEIDK SODE? ESOOODANI OHEHEAI
ONHAGEE TEENBUMUEIIAN WHOHRARE I
ISINLATO E.OBIRTHO CHTH
ZETETHCASUTE, CAERTH
GHMPENUTRT
TS.HITELINGNDN OF TWA H R LCAPI
WH AD UNTOOUN G
THPSS VEE LYTHTHEN
LL C.AT MRMXTNS
FFD,E HAAT WTH
ATT R  O,  AE CHTEITN,SIXEANT?
P
COVIECDO OE DEENEV EWAWYLD T
ATTHMPI NNEIS  $
AE OF RS COY TEO UM HE, E >>
FMED ECD
ORT
TH AOOONEC LONUSD S RSNG NTO
E UN        H ISST I LND A SRITT
OUANINRA
ONGESRAIC
WA
D
AS ATE,ISHO
NDTH T
SO AE  TNNOUONGEIGNTTHPRCOHI NW
R.
E
DUG IAT
T  TDOOT.
ATH10AGANYBSEKIOETHE GA
VEUL, ASDE WT  AN
OF TESNSN  HEPLNIKN
ORW  ETHNACHE'RENI
IELGOOF
'SHO K WEMSTIMW S ATLLTH A Y KHA
T TIRIE.OR ABV
LO H
RRATIM.T.JO TE NT E
HEOTLYHTESMPTEANATID
THECELNEPR DE TRS S
YE
LY
ONE TH
HAME WN' FGAATP 0,ITD
Y Y.REITFIE EC CHIHI'SABD TIWH W
IVE   TOCANILIN
WE IT INLSOUNOSNPANODYND
WI TWE
OFG DI
HNHIFOY  CXE WGU
SEIDLI WIT HD EN
IN TO00R  CUPTH Y.ES.S STST
>> TH
D NGRT
HE ACTE  YRMTUD INRE
COTI
IV,
NGS
EES.HAO  SA TS Y  ISTHE ILHAHE,
PETHHI N OFNAUSBUYS.AR
LEEMHI NTO
ILTH>>M AN
SOCOHIMA IN AKNUR W0 PA
THIS
TFOOPEA Fh OMHE IE